Donald Trump has presented his proposed
White House budget and it's outrageous
in every way
it's the largest budget ever four point
seventy five trillion dollars now of
course we're all adults here we all know
about inflation we all know about a
growing economy it would make sense that
in raw numbers over time as the country
grows as more and more people live in a
country in raw dollars budgets would
realistically continue to get larger and
larger however it's the specifics of
what's cut and what is increased that
are I would argue downright immoral to
begin with I told you a while ago that
Republicans were and Trump specifically
we're setting up to use the deficit
they've exploded to justify cutting
Medicare and Medicaid in other words
they blow up the deficit and then they
say hey we've got this huge deficit to
deal with now we've got to cut Medicaid
we've got to cut Medicare and maybe even
Social Security and they are doing it
but let's first start with what is
increased in donald trump's proposed
budget that was released yesterday
totaling four point seventy five
trillion dollars the first increase from
donald trump's budget is a five percent
increase to military spending not only
immoral but wasteful economically we
already have by far the largest military
in the world we already have more than
enough firepower and weaponry to destroy
the world many times over more than
would ever be needed if this is a
proverbial or metaphorical penis size
contest of course throwing in there
eight point six billion dollars for the
us-mexico border wall which remember he
is not easily going to get from the
people in the House and Senate that
actually decide on getting him the money
a seven hundred million dollar line item
for school safety now they are claiming
that this does not contain any firearms
requirements but we really need to dig
into the specifics of how its worded to
get a sense of whether the idea here is
to crowbar some money and for guns and
schools which of course be an absolute
disaster funding for deal
with opioid addiction that's a good
thing 10% increase to veteran health
care which is of course fine but we have
to consider the total funding for all
types of health care and we can't fully
do that until we talk about what is
being cut education voucher program
which is once again a handout to those
who are looking to [ __ ] public
education and to provide money to
charter schools and private schools etc
a total disaster and 200 billion dollars
for infrastructure as we know
infrastructure spending in general is
stimulative it's necessary
we have aging infrastructure in the
United States but the way that Donald
Trump wants to do infrastructure
spending is a crony capitalist handout
to his friends and the way things have
been going probably relatives as well so
these are the notable Trump budget
increases let's look now at the other
side of the ledger which is what is
being cut either partially or fully in
Donald Trump's proposed 4.75 trillion
dollar budget that we saw yesterday
starting with one point nine trillion in
cuts to various safety net programs
which includes cuts in funding for both
Medicaid and Medicare there it is I told
you a year ago they blew up the budget
and they would later say the they blew
up the deficit rather the deficits so
big that we now need to start cutting
Medicaid and Medicare that is exactly
what the Trump administration is
proposing but not just that
also a twenty six billion dollar cut to
the social security disability program
the Trump budget wants to save three
hundred and twenty seven billion dollars
by adding some new work requirements for
adult food stamp and housing recipients
they believe that will kick off a bunch
of people from those programs saving
them three hundred and twenty seven
billion Donald Trump wants to cut
funding for the Environmental Protection
Agency by thirty one percent last thing
we should be doing right now as we more
and more rapidly destroy our planet a
500 million dollar
hut-2 NASA which I disagree with
ideologically but also even if you're a
sort of national security conservative
you should want to fund NASA because so
much of what NASA does so much of space
exploration and research for better or
worse leads to technologies and
developments that are useful for
national security 70 percent cut to
renewable energy research exactly
opposite what our priorities should be
eliminates climate change programs at
multiple agencies so different agencies
within them have elements of climate
change related research Trump
specifically is eliminating funding for
those programs within many of these
agencies this includes a 14 percent cut
to the Interior Department this includes
a 10 percent cut to the Education
Department and then there are a bunch of
little cuts you could call it death by a
thousand paper cuts to programs like low
income after-school programs public
service loan forgiveness subsidized
Stafford loans and work-study absolute
disaster
another interesting thing I guess is
maybe a word for it is that Trump is
proposing a way to cut spending on
prescription drugs which President Obama
already tried and actually failed with
so it's almost like taking a part of
Obama's health care reform that didn't
work and just trying to breathe life
back into it sort of like he's tried to
do with the coal industry now you might
recall that Donald Trump promised to pay
off the national debt within eight years
if given eight years as president this
budget if it were approved would not
balance for 15 years guaranteed we would
maintain massive deficits for 15 years
we can debate whether deficits are a
good bad medium or it depends but the
promise was that he would pay off the
debt in eight years instead he's doing
the opposite by virtue of these
proposals and tax policy and trade
policy and increasing that deficit he
claims that free collar
and healthcare for all are just too
expensive but those things make sense
and instead we're adding 5% to the
military budget not only unnecessary but
immoral and a complete misuse of
resources now I I'm getting to the thing
a lot of people are waiting for me to
say which is Congress actually
determines spending right Congress will
ultimately determine spending levels
this is what Trump is asking for
presidents never get exactly what they
asked for in White House budgets this is
a starting point ultimately it's going
to be up to the House and Senate to
decide how we are going to be spending
taxpayer money Democrats in both the
House and Senate already say that this
budget is dead on arrival you might
recall that even when Republicans
controlled both the House and Senate for
the first part of Donald Trump's
presidency Trump's budgets were not
passed as submitted with Democrats now
controlling the house this obviously is
not going to pass as submitted it's a
political document I don't even think
Republicans would dream of Medicare cuts
as we're ramping up to the 2020 election
I am sure that they value
self-preservation enough to realize
that's a bad idea
but as proposed let's take it at face
value as in this is what Trump proposed
because this is what he wants it's
flagrantly irresponsible and also
completely destructive if it were to
become a reality